foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys and uh I will be in
Vegas I will be in Charlotte I will be
in Knoxville
um I've got a bunch of dates coming up
going over to crystallia.com to check
that out
um it's going to be a rip roaring good
time and the Don't Push Me Tour uh I'll
also be in Little Rock Arkansas
Nashville I've got uh Canada coming up
Pittsburgh Detroit Orlando Fort Myers
Richmond Virginia I'm going to a lot of
different places Philadelphia
um so go to chrisley.com and get those
tickets uh we've got the
um also the uh
Pockets stay deep collection with little
they come with little diving boards on
the pocket uh of the shirt and the pants
so a little little wink for you guys
there you know what I mean and then also
we've got the grower die merch up Live
Now selling like hotcakes so without
further Ado let's go to the new episode
of congratulations
[Music]
congratulations
how we been good yeah we've been good
you know
um I've been working out as you know my
Instagram video I've been talking about
how I do legs legs is my thing dude my
trunk's gonna get real strong I'll tell
you
um I know a lot of guys go in there and
they do chests you know and they try to
get their back all nice and yeah look
I'm all about pulling and I'm all about
squatting and um you know I'm doing the
deadlifts but dude
you're gonna see me this summer dude I
know it's already the summer but you're
gonna see me in a month or two and I'm
gonna be [__] Rumple still skin I
swear to God my shit's gonna pop out
um but yeah dude so uh I I feel really
good uh I went to uh where did I go uh
last weekend I went to Colorado Springs
oh and Pueblo dude I'm gonna actually
post this on
not this channel but my other channel
crystalline my crystalia channel going
over and subscribe to that by the way
subscribe here make sure you're
subscribed and uh like the video and
leave a comment but um what do you call
it I I I'm gonna post the video because
I did this
um show
in Pueblo
Colorado which I didn't even know about
about it I didn't know about that this
was a place okay and it's so uh not even
necessarily a place that uh I went to
Colorado Springs to do a show I was
supposed to do Pueblo and then Colorado
Springs and I went to Colorado Springs
from the Denver Airport I flew in flew
into the Denver Airport and I went to
Colorado Springs and stayed there and
drove to Pueblo to do the publish show
and came back to do the Colorado Springs
show so I stayed in Colorado Springs
only and the reason why I did that is
because Pueblo is Gang Related and
that's okay but it's got a lot of uh you
know uh gang activity there and I didn't
know this but my tour manager wanted to
do Pueblo just to try it you know it's
summer it's not really a time that
people like perform or uh comedians
really are on the road I'm like dude
let's do it I want to get out there I
kind of want to go to these weird places
I like going to these weird places I
like going to these places where maybe
comedians don't go to right
um
and so I went to go to do the Pueblo
show with the crew and you know look
yeah sure of course the city's dog [__]
but whatever it doesn't matter right we
still go there we play for it right I've
been Albuquerque before okay and this
was not a far cry from Albuquerque
um and whatever I make fun I make light
of the situation and I know the they say
that the city's on the come up although
I said that to actually let me tell the
story first
um I go to Pueblo and we get there and
uh
first of all there was supposed there
were people going on and on about how
there was going to be a protest for
Chrisley coming to
Pueblo
dude oh
dude two people showed up man
they tried to organize it so hard
two people showed up man
and then uh just a thousand people
walked by him you know it's just so
ridiculous that these people just want
to have a good time these people just
want to have a good time and people
think it's their business support that's
what it is I guess we live in America
you do whatever you want but everyone so
I I was making fun of that situation on
stage and I'm gonna post it on my
channel on YouTube
um but it's great dude it's so it's
hilarious that people are protesting
because they want like people just want
to have a good time and laugh and dude
if you Google Pueblo Colorado it's in
the top 10 most crime-ridden cities and
worst decrepit cities in America
just and everyone just wants to come
have a good time and literally laugh
and there's two people outside they're
just like no
um what a crazy crazy world we live in
dude it's so crazy
um so yeah everybody walked by those
people and then and then those people
immediately went home
they started off across the street like
like and then they walked over because
they were feeling and dude
we made sure to tell the security make
sure nobody like is shitty to the
protesters because we didn't want
anything bad to happen
um to the protesters because you know
people think that like
I we were just like dude you know hey
guys make sure that there that nothing
happens to the actual protesters which
is what we made sure to to have happen
because that's the last thing we want
but um it was very funny that everyone
just walked by and um
and then
I was on stage and I was making fun of
that roasting them and everyone was
laughing and they didn't even get to
[__] hear it which is really too bad
but
um
uh I was on stage and I did started
doing my ACT about 30 minutes in I I'm
like
this is Pueblo it's got It's going I'm
I'm doing well I'm having a good time on
stage you know
um
and I just decided to dip into the crowd
and start talking into the crowd because
some guys out there just literally in
the in the middle of the
um
of the uh
uh uh crowd and he's going like this
like
like the least gangster place to be at
is having a good seat in a comedy show
you know so
I'm like bro what's going on you know
I'm gonna put the video I said what's
going on he's I was like are you a
gangster and he was like yeah and I
asked him and um I did a bunch of crowd
work with him it's like 30 minutes long
I'm gonna put it on my YouTube but
um
it was a just
it was very fun I was making fun of them
I didn't do my act for the rest of the
30 minutes I did an hour on stage
whatever so I did 30 minutes material
and then 30 minutes of that and um
and uh it was so uh it was just then
people were like hitting me up
afterwards like man sorry about my [__]
my city these people [__] suck and I
didn't even really I was having a good
time it's been a while since I've done
some crowd work and [__] but I was
looking over because I was like I was
talking [__] about how the city is so uh
violent I mean it had 30
homicides last year like and it has a
hundred thousand people there like
that's so bad
30 people
got [__] homicide against them
and there's a hundred thousand people in
the in Pueblo so
uh I looked over there were there were
two uh
cops like just because it was a rat
because it's Pueblo there were two cops
on the side of the stage and I I look
over to them as I'm roasting the city
and they're [__] laughing like I see
their shiny badges just up and down
laughing and I'm like hell yeah that's
so [__] awesome I get off stage and
then I walk over to the cops are there
and I walk over and I say uh hey uh
oh they were laughing they're like man
you did a great job he was like you sure
he's like you sure did your research on
this city and I was like oh that's
hilarious yeah now there were 30
homicides last year and and he said I
know and what's crazy is we're homicide
detectives and I was like you are
and he was like yeah they were 30
homicides last year and I said well I
hear that the place is kind of on the
come up and it's kind of like being
gentrified and they laughed and they
were like no dude
it was great it was great it was a great
time I made it a great time you know but
then the um
the the sound guy or the uh light guy
came up to my videographer and he was
like Sam it came up to Sam and he was
like man I didn't know I thought you
know I've seen comedians I thought Chris
was going to buckle you know because
they were starting to yell out and [__]
and I'm like bro that's just not gonna
happen and and and he was like yeah like
[__] two comedians came last last
month or something and they just had
they just ate plates of [__]
he told me who they were I'm not going
to mention who they were but yeah dude
that's not I'm not standing for that
I will
I will I will not stand for that so we
had a great show it was fun very fun
um and I got on a plane well actually on
the way there
um
he there were two there was a guy
who who was sitting down already and
then another guy walked over with his
daughter and little like she was like
maybe
not even two
and this man walked up to the guy and
said hey
um I think you're in my seat
and the guy said oh I'm not and I just
go I just in my head I go here we go
here we go
somebody's wrong don't you love it when
an argument starts and it's like okay
clear-cut somebody's [__] wrong and I
I just can't wait because I can't wait
to see who it is
right it's not like hey dude the
vaccines don't you know don't really
help well they do because of this in a
while did you hear about this and this
and this and then you leave and you're
like I wonder if those vaccines honestly
if they hump or not
you know it's not like dude I think the
Mets are going all the way this year and
they're like oh yeah well what about the
Pittsburgh Pirates because of this and
this this I think you leave thinking I
wonder if it's gonna be the match of the
Pittsburgh Pirates or maybe someone else
this is clear
the guy walks walks and says hey you're
in my seat sir and the guy says no this
is my seat so I just I'm ready
and he says well I'm in um
I'm in uh one
what was it
um
I'm in one C
and the guy says
well where's C
B
and the guy says I don't know but you're
in my seat and he says
this is c b
and the guy says no it's it's C and the
guy says where's Big
and the guy says I don't know but you're
in my seat and the guy and then another
guy next to me gets up walks over to
them and says Hey sir you're in the
wrong seat
he says you're in the wrong seat you
need to be nice
ah the guy next to me gets up walks a
full like
call row or whatever like two up and
says Hey sir you're in the wrong seat
you need to be nice and the guy says
well where's seat B and the guy says
I don't know man and he says you're not
listening to me and he says I don't know
where seat D is okay so he thinks he's
saying D the whole time and the guy has
got a by the way the guy in the seat has
a mask on so he pulls his mask out he
says you're not understanding me
where is seat b or whatever the [__] it
was between b and d and he says I guess
it's over there but this is seat C and
then
he gets up
and moves the seat and the guy next to
me comes back to me and said and I
because I'm so curious at this point
like why is this guy getting involved
and I said oh did you have like an
altercation with that guy earlier or
something because like that's what it
was like it was like okay I'm mad about
something else and this guy's still
acting up even though it's not to me I'm
going to say something
and he comes and he sits down next to me
and I say oh did you have like a thing
with that guy earlier or something he
says no he's just being a jerk
dude and I said ah okay
I don't know what it is about the
airport and airplanes it's just people
are are like okay so here's what's going
on I'm gonna be a a big [__] and or
put people in their place immediately
like way too soon and also I'm gonna
only be wearing socks
that's I don't understand what is wrong
with people when they go to the airport
it's like people walk into the airport
and they think like all right let's see
who how are we doing this all right
sup that's what people walk into the
airport like sup how are we gonna do
this who's ruining my day and how can I
tell them
it's so weird
I try to chill as hard as I can on the
airport at the airplane at the airport
because like I'm like it's just not I'm
not I I first of all last thing I could
you know it's like [__] tweets out oh
crystallia was a piece of [__] at the
airport but also like
I just I don't
I don't know
this my whole attitude is this sucks
we're gonna get there
it's gonna suck if you suck you're not
even really adding to the suckiness this
already sucks
you know we're too close to each other
I you know the food anytime someone will
bring food out it's gonna smell like
like somebody literally put [__] bone
Jay Bojangles Chicken just right in my
nostril
so uh
yeah dude it was great it was so funny
though how ready that guy next to me was
just to get involved
um
we stayed in Colorado Springs and uh you
know Colorado Springs is a good uh
the tour report are probably cool but
the the Colorado Springs is uh
uh really
bitching dare I say
it's got beautiful mountains we took
those scooters all over the place
and uh I was with Denny and Lulu and Sam
and David and uh Enrique and
uh it was just like
um the first day there was
a
um
the first day there was a uh
car show which had like crazy old cars
and new cars and [__] and that was
pretty cool then the second day there
was just like a cookout on the Block
like people were just cooking Burgers on
like a street in in a Main Street
and like there were like people just
dancing I didn't really understand it
was like you fall asleep and dream about
the city you just went to and you're
like oh you had a dream where they were
like cooking burgers on the Main Street
there just outside
um so many Rainbow Flags like super
gayed up there in Colorado Springs
honestly Colorado's pretty gate up and
that's fine uh but they are pretty gate
up like if you're not gay they go like
you should be gay and um
we went to the we just we we were
driving by these scooters and we go by
this club
32 it's called Club 32.
and this woman is out there I mean she's
got to be in her 50s
uh bleach blonde hair the owner of it
again I came to find out but she's like
hey what are you guys doing come on in
and it's like
two
and we're like huh nobody's on the
street everything's closed come on in
you guys where you guys from
we're like la oh great come on in and
I'm like does she know who I am or what
come on in we're just hanging out
we walk in she texts us up hey it's good
to see you guys
there's this place is huge it's enormous
and it's called Club 32 and it is uh
the lights are still going it's closed
and there's five people there and two
bartenders and five people that are like
60.
so I'm like but this is a place where
like 20 something year olds go to
so I'm like what is this
she's like can I get you guys drinks
okay we get club soda and all that [__]
she's like what are you guys doing in
town like we're working and she's like
oh yeah what do you do you're like oh we
do we do stand up and she was like uh oh
wait you have a show and it's like yeah
the DJ's there it's so loud he's just
like yeah yeah welcome to Club 32 with
just five of us all right all right we
got ludicrous coming up just playing
music
um
good music I thought and so you know 30
minutes go by and I'm like what the [__]
is going on what are we doing you know
and beat I'll be damned if I didn't say
we went for [__] we stayed in
Colorado Springs nights we went every
[__] night to that club
was a strange mix of fun and not fun and
I will tell you uh we went
to
we went to uh the Club 32 and a bunch of
them came to my show the next night
uh not that lady but like a bunch of the
bartenders and the the DJ and as soon as
we got to the club afterwards was like
[__] Crystal Lee is here every
[__] Crystal here Chris Lewis that of
comedian [__] yeah he's here and uh
after that he says and we got a
celebrity in the house and I'm like he
just did me who else is here and he says
give it up for Old Dirty bastard's son
Old Dirty Bastard young Dirty Bastard
and I look and sure enough it looks like
[__] old dirty bastard son who I
guess goes by Young Dirty Bastard I
don't know does he are you looking it up
now
does it go by that or no anyway he
called him young Dirty Bastard and he
was just out there just [__] chilling
I was like oh I got two [__] he goes
by that wow so I got two celebrities
here Chris Lee and young Dirty Bastard
wow pretty cool I guess he raps I don't
know but dude um and then we went to eat
and we left and said and and David who
we had a waitress there and David
um
was taking a like Dilly dallying coming
out we got on the scooters
and David's like hey Sam to my cameraman
he's like I for no reason Sam did not
tell him to do this but he was like Hey
you uh
I got that girl's number for you and he
was like who and he was like the
waitress I told her you I told her you
liked her
and Sam's like really and he's like yeah
she wants you to text her and he was
like oh okay he said she said go to
these bars and he says uh she says
you'll really like the bar icon
and I was like oh how did she know he's
like I just she thought you'd like it
she's like all right she's like let's
drive by icon we go to Icon dude
it is
not only have rainbow
Windows it is the gayest Place dude the
[__] no [__] the security guy was
literally like like this like with a
clipboard like waiting and dude we were
we were laughing like oh dude not that
there's anything wrong with it but dude
she said you're doing dude she even know
him dude
she got him dude
[Music]
um
but it was literally it couldn't have
been gayer
so Sam I guess you know
is gay according to her
um
big practical joke on us
we just drove around scooters really
enough about the [__] weekend you can
watch your tour report though
I woke up one morning and like probably
six A.M
and
I can't remember last time this happened
but have you when's the last time
you woke up and you're and you're like
one of your limbs was numb okay that's
happened to me a bunch of times in my
life obviously as it has you I woke up
and it was so numb
dude how come every time it happens when
you wake up in your arms um it every
time you wake up you just think this is
it it's not gonna come back
it's not coming back not this one
dude and it's so heavy and so big
feeling and it's so [__] numb I don't
even like feeling it and I'm trying so
hard to [__] grip something and I
can't it's just flopping around like
it's my dick
and dude
it was so numb that I resigned to the
fact immediately that it was not coming
back and it took so long and I was like
what am I going to do how's my life
gonna be
like just in Colorado Springs wake up at
6am how's my life going to be I guess it
could be okay I can hold the microphone
with this hand and then slowly but
surely it came back and then I laid back
down and went back to sleep bro
like the fact that all of that happened
in the middle of my sleep and then also
I wasn't saying a word like I was so
tired and then went back to sleep and I
haven't told [__] a soul about it
until now is hilarious
like I was so stressed out didn't utter
a word
and just waited and prayed to the gods
that my [__] arm would come back and
it did
um
how about this [__] Lana Del Rey
thing
I guess she was she had you know what I
don't get
musicians and I thought that kind of
rappers just did this but like musicians
that
are so late to perform
like I've never started my show more
than 20 minutes late and you've I don't
even think I've started more than
it's been always less than 20.
unless no even when there was no I've
never done that I've never done it more
than that but Lana Del Rey I guess got
on stage so so late it was she was
supposed to do like a 40 minute set
got on stage at 11 45 and there was a
hard curfew at midnight like some places
are either state-owned or you know just
you can't go over 12 midnight because of
a certain law
and they cut her mic at 11 45 or I'm
sorry at 12. so she did 15 minutes and
everyone [__] litter up because she
they were like we we paid for this
[__] for your concert bro imagine
people came to see me and I did 15
minutes
and that was it I mean I do a full hour
at least but like
so not worth it it's also
even doing 35 minutes it's like these
ticket prices are so high what what what
um
place was it
you know
it was a music festival and she was
supposed to go on
yeah go right Glastonbury yeah
and the reason she gave on stage was
that she was lazy because my hair takes
so long eh
oh dude she's my wife
oh dude she's my wife oh I dude
honey are you Lana Del Rey dude I had no
idea she's my wife that's crazy I'm
married to Lana Del Rey
um
look Lana Del Rey late for Glastonbury
set my hair takes so long to do hit
Glastonbury
um
wow
oh my god dude that's so
man I tell
female you know like just
start earlier
I don't understand it this is like the
bane of married guy's existences too
like dude I [__] sometimes lie don't
tell my wife I sometimes rely and tell
her we gotta [__] be ready
15 minutes earlier do you guys do that
or you like me don't tell her though
because one time she was like did you
lie and do we actually have to go at
seven and I was like what
no
she was like okay
it's 6 50 she's
still and I'm just like No And I want to
be like yeah I did see because look
because look what happened we're late
right now aren't we isn't that true
right so I did what I do can we say with
me the right thing one two three the
right thing thank you very much you
didn't say it but
dude I tell her I'm gonna tell her start
telling her a full half hour doesn't
matter what I could tell her a whole
hour she'll she'll know she'll know and
it will still happen
hey sorry hey sorry we're late but you
know that's me every time I want to be
like sorry we're late but you know dude
I got a Lana Del Rey over here
right her hair takes so long and [__]
and every guy is always well why don't
you start earlier you don't understand
there's a lot to because women will be
like there's a lot to there's a lot and
we also and then
if they have a baby they're like because
of the kids and if they don't they're
just like it's just stressful because of
the the way society and you're like oh
well just don't wear makeup then I love
you without makeup you don't understand
the pressure okay you know what I don't
know
you know what I don't understand the
pressure I understand the pressure of we
got to be there on time how about that
pressure though
and her with the she acts like great the
grace period well there's a grace period
when she fully doesn't know right I
guess that's like a known thing at like
restaurants
there's a great dude she was late to the
[__] dry bar the other day
to blow her hair out she was
15 minutes late and they don't give a
[__] dude dry bars are like Nazis I
swear to God
you you got to get there you've got to
like it's like school
like when you when you when you get
there and you're late and you're like
you're late and you're like yeah but
there was a line and they were like well
what are you gonna say at work though
one second when you say work what
happens in real life
sit down
that's what they would always do at my
high school and [__] but um she was like
10 minutes no 15 minutes late to the dry
bar and she was she called me and she
was like can you believe
and I'm already like
well I gotta say I can't believe it you
know like I can't like I can't
by the way I already believe it and I
don't even know what she's gonna say but
she's like can you believe I was 15
minutes late and I was there and I was
looking for parking there was no parking
and I go oh I see where this is going
and she says and there was a line okay
and I was in the place
probably 10 minutes late but then the
line took like five minutes and then
and I got there and they were like
um sorry you're here too late and I was
like oh what about the great spirit and
they said well we don't do it anymore
they're [__] Nazis over there I swear
to God for real a dry box they're just
like you uh two minutes late we have no
grace period sit there sit and Zach yeah
right there it's electric hahaha
um stand right there against that pole
because there we go nobody if you'll be
late here at Dry Bar
um
we turn up if you are we turn up the
blow dryer is extra hot we burn your
scalp we take it off we make lamps out
of it
lamp shades so um
so
she says can you believe it they didn't
and then the lady was like so shitty
about it but my wife is the sweetest
person like if anyone she's the kind of
woman that if like somebody's shitty to
her it's that that's it's them she's
like the sweetest person she never wants
any confrontational altercation she just
like
if if she comes back and she's like this
person was a dick I know they were a
dick okay
so she's like and I waited in line for
like eight minutes and they were like
trying to say I was too late and I was
like I was in line
and she was like well you have to be
here earlier you got to make sure you're
not in the line she was like but do
people over here are waiting what's the
difference if I do it she's like can't
do it just to draw back and in my head
while I'm on the phone I was like I'm
like oh that sucks but in my head I'm
like sure I'm feeling right
you gotta learn somehow don't you this
is do you know what this is this is real
life
because you know it's not behind you
know it's not behind that [__] little
Clerk's desk you know it's not behind
that a husband that can get in trouble
if he yells
right you know it's not behind that
little [__] iPad that you gotta sign
and tip right you know what you know
what's not behind that
a significant other that if he yells too
much it's gonna it's gonna make you cry
and then they're gonna feel bad about it
they don't give a [__]
they want you to feel bad that's
customer service
customer service doesn't give a [__]
because nobody likes their job and
that's fine it's hard enough to get a
job get a job obviously disgruntled I
mean I've called customer service I said
oh really you don't care well I'm an
aired out of my podcast and she said
that's good I don't give a [__] and hung
up that happened
so customer service doesn't give a [__]
dude
but dry bar is a great company honestly
who knew that you could make a [__]
company blow dry in women's hair they
were probably laughing at that who's the
lady I forget Ali something she was on
Shark Tank
dude and she just was like I'm gonna
blow I'll do it
I go no that's not gonna work
boom dude
anyway dude don't start your sets late
man
the the sub disaster is just
obviously I gotta talk about this I got
to talk about this uh because of how
it's very obvious that it's the number
one thing everyone's talking about I
don't I
I think I found out it was happening
last podcast but this time it's like
okay
now I kind of know what happened these
guys four guys went down in a tin
can that was not big they went they did
I don't think they had shoes on like I
think they were like we're not wearing
shoes like
it was very haphazard they got warnings
not to go
um
they
were billionaires of course
because they thought they were God and
that's fine
um
there was not a real toilet
they had to like [__]
on the outs on the inside and then I I
guess they released it somehow into the
water I I don't I don't know honestly
but they were like hey the the Glass
isn't is on is good for 2 000 feet of
pressure and the Titanic is four
thousand feet down there so
it broke it concaved it [__] everyone
died immediately
you know
[__] came out of their head their
eyeballs came out of their anus whatever
it was it was terrible
and they all did it because they had a
lot of money and they wanted to go near
this which by the way
it had one window they wanted to go down
to see the summer the Titanic they
didn't even [__] go to get this like
it's like it was 250 000 not worth it of
course to them the billionaires doesn't
matter one of the guys took his son who
didn't want to go but it was Father's
Day super sad
um there's all the stuff that you know
they got warnings and not to go went
died and um
hey everybody
chill the [__] out about it huh
don't be dicks
it's so sad this happened and people are
literally like yeah these [__] piece
of [__] Rich billionaires [__] them
hey they died
that's so sad people don't give a [__]
online
yeah should they have not gone right yes
they definitely should not have gone
they wound up just like the Titanic they
[__] sank and died and it sucks you
know they didn't even get to see
Leonardo DiCaprio's body and
it's sad and that's it and
all these jokes the people were the
quickest to write these jokes they're so
there's so I can't stand Comics the
thing that happens and they got to do it
immediately they're so [__] they're
so like it's so awful that oh this is
funny I'll make a joke about it
immediately it's just like dude have
some [__] I don't even know respect
is the right word but like
for a joke to get a [__] retweet
and not just Comics do it everybody does
it uh well not everybody but a lot of
people do it
um and it was so sad dude
um and I I just I'm like God I think
about this [__] differently now that I
have a family of my own you know
I mean could you think of anything more
sad
all over the news
and it's crazy too and I'm not woke and
I [__] hate woke people but like uh a
ship sank the next day or something with
like 500 immigrants and I I didn't even
know about it until somebody told me and
I'm just like wow the media dude
um
yeah
how about the [__] flash people are
like oh yeah people like the CGI is
really bad and they were like oh yeah no
we meant to that's the best
they said people are like wow some of
the worst seeds I ever saw and they're
like oh we meant to
the guy was like well we were meant to
because we wanted to [__] because it
was through the Flash's head it was
through his eyes and he was imagining it
bad sit not
um
we gotta go we've been on this DJ Khaled
train so we might as well
this guy won't stop huh
I cover Chandelier
guys what's up
[Music]
I caught with Chandelier
but I mean cut cut already you know the
worst cut I call her Chandelier
when he says what's the [__] what in
tarnation voice that he always does dude
he's really holding on to that one did
you see the cappuccino one
it's a cappuccino I call it cappuccino
my friend said that to me let me find it
it's right here
here it is
right here
[__]
I don't say this but it's [__] suit
oh my golf clubs my sneakers I said so
much setup
um I name everything I call this
cappuccino got right into it so quickly
it looked just like a cappuccino it has
a cappuccino I call it cappuccino okay
dude so the car is a cappuccino color I
guess it's like brownish tan whatever
and then he also has a cappuccino and so
you obviously want to make this video so
here we go he keeps going yep
it gotta it gotta feel like an Al Pacino
like trying to bring out the cappuccino
I mean it's got to feel like Al Pacino
for no reason he said that
it's a cure
to this guy
is awesome
pointing to his shoes because they're
the same color as the
only real news is
reading himself
[Music]
a magazine with him on the cover not
saying [__] now
oh God
oh this guy's on another level
tell him to bring out the cappuccino
call it the chandelier and it never
cause things what they actually are
just gonna invent a different language
he has a marketing genius honestly when
he would when he did the thing like they
don't want us to that's the he is a
genius this guy
and I'm super mad about it I'm a hater
no we love him
I I I make a lot of fun but I anybody
who finds who finds who who finds their
bag honestly that's it they did it no
hate
um the the
um
the uh
I want to talk about that but hold on I
want to look at this first
oh dude oh this is so funny bro
I don't even understand how this can be
real but it is
this is so funny this went viral a
little bit ago and I thought I saw it
and then I was and then I was like why
didn't I ever talk about this
on a plane if you want to talk to me
about being okay okay dude
just logic all out the window
that is so great how did this guy be
alive this long you know what I'm saying
he just he's 50. so is the baby
sure you're yelling
guys I hope you guys have kids you can't
stop a baby from yelling it's a baby
you know
did that [__] pay extra to yo it
didn't pay [__] first of all first of
all babies fly free second of all
doesn't have a wallet
it's a baby does this guy not understand
what a baby is
what if it wasn't a baby and they were
just
and this is a guy with a mustache and he
was just like ah ah just crying the
whole time
oh good dude someone says shut up he
says
[__] you and shut up oh this guy is
beyond the the brain just broke and it's
beyond and he's just like well there's
no turning back you know what I'm saying
like I already did the thing and he's
like here come more things
I don't give a [__] he so doesn't give a
[__] you know it's so funny when you
don't give a [__] that much you give a
[__] so much
[__]
[Music]
Focus today
bro
the guy is so mad at someone who's not
even one
with a baby and a goddamn Echo chain
here it is right here
we go
and there it is on [__]
the way he hit it so hard like here
comes my point that's going to be
absolutely something you can't come back
from
I don't understand even
this is crazy
so is the baby singing it
it's so weird
um
hold on
the neck hump
I'm a Cairo I'll show you how to fix it
take a tad like this and roll it up fun
place right at the base of yours how
could you be so off
this is a doctor dude I see so many
Chiropractic videos on [__] uh
Twitter or uh what is it tick tock it's
unbelievable
dude I don't want to go to chiropractors
man
I went once and guess what it doesn't do
feel that good yay he said it yay dude
they go hold this I go
just cracking all over the [__] place
and then they go 65 bucks or whatever it
is I don't remember
and then you leave and they're like how
do you feel and you are like wow that's
great but really all you did was hear a
bunch of sounds
dude
and then you go on Tick Tock and these
[__] there's one guy who does
it to like chickens I swear to God he's
just like they call it Farm hands are
like hey my my chicken's different he's
like all right let me take her here we
go you hear that
and it's just too much dude
um and I never feel any different and I
just it feels like it's not gonna dude
I don't want to do anything that's why I
haven't gotten laser eye surgery which I
think I need to get at some point but
like any time you like a millimeter
difference can [__] ruin you nah I'm
not gonna do it
no thanks dude
oh hey maybe I'll get some sort of uh uh
what do they call it a placebo effect
that makes me feel like my back is
better for nine minutes or maybe I'll
never walk again no thanks
you know what I'm saying or may oh okay
yeah maybe I will trick myself into
making the left side of my body feel a
little less tense or perhaps the last
time I went to the [__] toilet is the
last time I'll go to the toilet because
now I'll just be [__] and pissing my
pants for the rest of my life
now I'll need a bag to catch it like
just it's crazy dude and when they do
the one where they just
they go to the top of your head and
you're laying down and they just [__]
and pull it or they pull your legs even
worse they tie up your thing they tie up
your head and then they they pull the
legs and and everyone's just like oh
yeah and then they get the guy that
cries or the woman that's like oh my God
so much relief now you're just scared
because you almost died
you're just a Saint Peter for a split
second he goes oh never mind sorry I
thought you just got hit by a train my
bad go ahead back to Earth
then there's this guy
I'm a Cairo I'll show you how to fix it
take it Tad like show off and roll it up
fun place right at the base of your neck
so bone right there just talking towel
and put it right there so bad lie on
your back and stretch out like this
I'm a Cairo
lying said it too much dude
this is a [__] Banger dude I'm going
this chiropractor are you the rapper
I walk in
I'm sorry
that's for real
just as good as hip-hop nowadays this
guy's killing him I'm a Cairo I'll show
you how to fix it take it tell like this
okay and roll it up okay now it's on the
place right at the base of your neck
with the bone right there the talking
towel so insert it right there lie on
your back and stretch out like this
and hold for four minutes I'm a Cairo I
mean not even something basically just
say lay on a [__] towel
ah also was he Australian or not you
know
Cairo I'm a Cairo
who [__] made him do that
oh God
she says [__]
patreon.com crystalia
you get the full extended
um thing
did you guys hear about this
this was crazy to me I tried to bring up
in the text chain but everyone was
against me
um
Toronto Blue Jays
fire
well
okay
this is all pretty wacky but the
Toronto Blue Jays dropped pitcher
Anthony Bass
for
anti-lgbtq comments now
I don't know so when you read that you
think okay he hates
gays and trans people that's what you
think maybe but if you're a little bit
smarter you'll be like oh wait a second
the media acts like your anti-lgbtq if
somebody tells you hey I'm trans and you
go oh
they act like because you do that
900 trans people are going to get hit by
a car right like if you're just not
totally like when someone says hey I'm
trans if you don't go give me a t and
have five people behind you T give me an
r r
oh Trans like if you don't do that
you're perpetuating
genocide you know what I'm saying like
that's what the media acts like if you
don't literally carry around a [__]
rainbow flag in Los Angeles if you live
here for at least two hours a day during
pride month
you're the reason that trans people are
dying
so that's what the media so and this is
by CNN which is woke [__] Central but
let's read it
all these [__] news outlets suck
[__] huge balls and dick
um
the Toronto Blue Jays have design
designated pitcher Anthony bat this is
where you come to the news from by the
way me dude we hit it hard Anthony bass
for assignment following and an anti so
what did he share I don't even know the
move comes hours before the Blue Jays
first game of Pride weekend there we go
and the team see this is the thing so
blue jays general manager so I know kind
of what happened a little bit
apparently he's like the best pitcher on
the team too
um
and
bass shared an Instagram post that
called for anti-lgbtq boycotts of Target
oh that's what he did right so this
wasn't even
something that he was saying right
um he posted well maybe it was but he
posted that there should be boycotts of
Target and Bud Light because Target
sells uh sexual underwear for children
which is [__] batshit crazy to me and
then Bud Light uh which I don't really
give a [__] about but they just have
that crazy Dylan Mulvaney
same
I'm a woman and drink Bud Light which I
don't care about at all because I don't
give a [__] I don't drink beer and also
I don't care that much and it doesn't
affect me in the least
um
but the lgbtq community uh
okay so he called it evil the post said
it was evil and demonic
which is a real buzzword for this like
any time someone says something about
like
there are people who are too far right
that when somebody says somebody is
trans that they think well that's the
devil in them and it's just like it's
like okay but there's no devil so what
are you don't be so ridiculous anyway
so the
people the woke mob took to the you know
I guess it was Twitter and mostly
Twitter probably and
um and they
basically forced quote unquote the
organization the Blue Jays organization
to tell Anthony bass to apologize for
the thing so he did
and
um
then also it's Toronto Jesus is so woke
uh so then
he got fired anyway because
it's never good enough for the woke it's
never [__] good enough for the far
left it's never good enough hey
apologize okay sorry oh you're gonna
[__] let this guy still have his job
they want make no mistake the woke
people are the biggest hey don't bully
us but the biggest bullies this is just
they are not happy until you end your
life this is just the truth
this is the only Power they have and it
works when it comes to corporations case
in point Toronto Blue Jays but um
yeah this guy was a pitcher and
apparently he had like he was like kind
of the best on the team and they just
got rid of them because he posted
something on his private tick tock on
his private uh Instagram not in uniform
now
let's rewind all the way to and I'll
I'll definitely get into some hot water
here but I don't actually give a [__] at
this point
um
what's his name
um Kaepernick right
kneeled knelt in before the game
in uniform
during business hours okay
uh
the woke people meaning the media
said to said how crazy it is that they'd
have a problem with this he should be
able to do this and people should be
able to stand for what they need to
stand for now
I am not saying I agree with Anthony
bass I am not saying I agree with Colin
Kaepernick I'm not saying I disagree
with them what I am saying is
if you
are somebody who wants to advocate for
free speech it's got to be all of it
it's got to be all of it and guess what
that's gonna [__] suck sometimes for
you but because people are going to say
[__] you don't agree with do I think
that trans people have the devil in them
no I don't okay
but I guess people are gonna have to say
that and some people are gonna have jobs
that say that and then when they say
that you got to just go like this wow
that person it sucks they're crazy
but because of that he can't throw a
ball the [__] that have to do with
anything
it is such a crazy [__] time we live
in and now uh I walk around just to
spite everyone
I think Anthony that's his greatest
pitcher ever lived
he can strikeout anybody
if he was around during Babe Ruth times
Babe Ruth wouldn't have got that many
home runs neither would Mickey Mantle
needed with Roger Maris neither would
Barry Bonds
um I do think though that it's crazy
what he was saying about how uh they
have the devil in them um because they
don't but whatever I'm just free speech
is a kind of a thing I go you know what
I go back and forth on I do believe in
it because I'm a I'm a comedian but also
like
I don't know there's a fine line of what
hate speech is uh I just don't like when
people act like because you uh are some
guy that's just like passively saying
your beliefs that you're you're the
reason why people [__] die because
that's not true silence isn't violence
violence is violence we've said that a
bunch on
on this podcast before and that's that
I also should say that because here's
the other thing too I had a buddy who
got kicked off of Instagram because he
was saying stuff about I don't remember
what it was either Trump or the vaccines
and he was like bro can you help me out
this is [__] up that like they took my
account down and it's free speech and I
don't get to say it now and it's
actually not because it's a business
like There are rules and guidelines you
have to go by about Instagram and it
sucks the rules are guys they have to go
to on YouTube we get flags sometimes for
saying [__] that you have to make sure
you're 18 to sign into the [__] thing
to watch the video and I'm sure we
spread miss all we do is spread
misinformation on this podcast that's
the point of this podcast and
um
you know it's well within YouTube's
right to be like this is not what we
want in our business just like it's well
within the right of the Toronto Blue
Jays to be like ah this guy doesn't
believe in what the [__] we believe in
so he's out of the [__] League
however my point still stands what the
[__] does that have to do with throwing
the ball and here's the other thing too
um fans are booing but they don't really
give a [__] that's the thing they're
booming because it's easy to boo they're
still at the [__] game
they're still at the game meaning they
still purchase the ticket so it's not
really hurting their pockets as a matter
of fact what moves hurt your pockets
so
you know I do believe in the fact that
Free Speech does stop when you talk when
you when it comes to a company right
because it has nothing to do with free
speech this is what the company might
stand for or not stand for if you go
against their guidelines then you're out
I get it
um which is what [__] the NFL was
kind of brushing up against with
Kaepernick because they were like well
we can't [__]
you know what I mean
we can't keep
it's bad luck and we're white and he's
black and we're all a bunch of old white
guys
but I get it
so yeah I don't know man it's just
not gonna watch that movie
um I'm never gonna watch a movie uh I
think right now I'll never watch a movie
of men okay so that's good and that's
what you come here for
um thanks for listening this has been
another episode of congratulations and
I'll tell you this much
um you can go over to the patreon and
watch the full episode patreon.com
crystalia we love you for it thank you
very much and the patreon episode drop
is dropping soon and it is Bonkers silly
so going over patreon.com crystalia
leave a comment dude right here and we
appreciate you
um thank you very much guys bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign